that jake here is making the legend of
jacob degrom and this is an important
year he's mentioned hall of fame already
in his career third sai young he's off
to a great start to me it's a body of
work over years jacob now is building
that body to put him in the same
stratosphere as tom terrific
and he blows away dickerson to start
this one
i tell you what i've seen the first two
starts now this is just the first batter
i just i think this fastball is the best
fastball that the groms ever had
and martay has blown away this time with
the slider so degrom with back-to-back
strikeouts to start the day oh my gosh
if one degrom weren't tough enough about
the left-hander
wha what town am i in
the man with two faces
in foul ground and alonzo drifting on it
and pete squeezes it and degroms got
himself a dominating
first inning through just nine pitches
no score as the mets come to back trevor
rogers the left-hander starting for the
miami marlins
degrom in september 579 on base
percentage leads the national league
and he lines one to left center that's a
base hit it's going to head toward the
gap
and go all the way to the wall
nimo digs for second and he's in
standing with a lead off double
with the orange shoes today
and drops down a bunt popping out his
wallet and he can't make the play and
the mets have runners at the corners
lindora bunts for a base hit and the
mets have first and third and nobody out
but the strike
as they'll throw down to second and
lindor is out
trying to
steal second against rogers nimo stays
put nice job there by wally
wow what a huge play my statement there
the strike supersedes the hit by pitch
there is strike three to conforto and
now all of a sudden the dynamic of this
inning really changes two outs first and
third lendor caught stealing then the
strikeout and then another rogers
bouncing right back freezes alonzo gets
a couple of strikeouts in the first
still scoreless
2-2 to cooper
and he gets him with a slider
third strike out of the first four
batters for the grump
open up a little bit with two strikes
and he gets blown away up by 101 five
batters
four strikeouts
two out of nobody on here is jazz
chisholm this will be his first career
played appearance against degrom
as jazz lifts one right field and that
might be too good of a strike how about
upper deck for jazz chisholm jr it's one
nothing marlins
short compact easy swing
easy swings at 100 miles an hour go a
long way
yeah they do just chisholm two balls two
strikes on dom smith james mccann to
follow there's another strikeout for
trevor rogers
that was uh
quite a bad part
no bad flip here as rogers works a 1-2-3
inning following a strike to chad
wallach and now wallach sends one to
left field that is going to one up and
get down toward the wall chad hustling
into second base with a leadoff double
[Applause]
depth influenced wallets lead yes
rogers takes strike three called that's
five now for degrom
[Applause]
there's a called strike three perfect
pitch from rogers he's got four
strikeouts
one game and one a b and another called
strike three 97 on the black five k's
through three for rogers
there goes martay swinging a miss
mccann's throw is a perfect one but
can't be handled by mcneil marte was
going to beat it anyway he got a good
jump but again
made it right on the money throw
martay nonetheless steals the bases
aguilar strikes out
and a foul tip held by mccann for
strength three
seven strikeouts for the grom second
time he's gotten cooper
across the grapefruit and cactus league
there's another strikeout make it six
and that will bring up conforto
and conforto down on strikes and uh
again give credit where credit's due
and he struck him out with the
eight strikeouts now for degrom so he
changed the game plan against chisholm
and comes up successful that's respect
with the capital r right there
kept his own stats
wallach strikes out
rojas at first with two out one and two
to trevor rogers
and he takes strike three call
ten strikeouts in five innings for the
ground 47th time in his career he's had
10 or more
[Applause]
that's to third
and the marlins go around the horn so
they erase that leadoff single nice job
by rogers to get the ground ball and
there are two outs in the fifth an
underlying theme for the marlins in the
early going as well rogers with another
strikeout
what a day he's having make it eight
through five one nothing
he'll be 33 this june
on the outside corner and he gets martay
for his 11th strikeout of the day
102. maddie struck him out with a high
fastball
that's an even dozen for degrom through
six innings
lined out the only pitch he saw his
first time up and this one's dribbled up
the line he may stay fair rogers with us
[Applause]
that was rogers ball all the way but
aguilar came in
and when rogers swept it over to him he
was nowhere near first base
i fly out to center field marta drifting
back he'll make the catch
tagging and heading to third is degrom
metz will have first and third with one
out
conforto is so worried about all that
velocity on the outside edge that you
kind of create a little hole underneath
your hands rogers has been able to
exploit that throughout the three at
bats today
ball and two strikes and a swing and a
miss nine strikeouts for rogers another
big one right there two outs in the
sixth
third time this afternoon to conforto
[Applause]
and he's got 10 strikeouts
matching a career high rogers fired up
good change up by degrom for his 13th
strike out of the day one shy of his
career high
one-two coming
he struck him out
14 strikeouts for degrom that matches
his career high fourth time he's done it
three of the four have come against
miami edwin diaz brought in to pitch the
top of the ninth
the marlins have a one-nothing lead
algae lar into center base hit marte
coming around third hey zeus aguilar has
given the marlins a two-nothing lead and
some much-needed insurance in the ninth
oh you gotta love this big man i'll tell
you what
anderson at second jazz at first
run in in the inning mickey grounds one
up the middle of base hit rounding third
coming home is anderson the marlins get
a couple in the ninth inning and open up
a three-nothing lead
[Applause]
need a big hit miggy's your guy
well he certainly is second hit of the
afternoon
one-two
called strike three
it's a marlins win trevor rogers
absolutely brilliant
this afternoon as the marlins bounce
back a tough one on thursday a
controversial ending they get a day off
to kind of forget everything they bounce
back today
battle battle battle with degrom